back at jingle ball matching sweaters
insane yes Incan patriot I wore
Backstreet Boy you didn't think I
remember that those it was impressive
Wow
what's the Duncan situation about these
were given to us and so we were like do
we wear ugly sweaters again he's like
yeah not to mention I also love Duncan
so yeah I love Duncan yeah yeah as well
not just the New England boy you know
like I was watching Tom Brady's press
conference earlier today and there was
the big Duncan behind it next to the
patron symbol honestly I think that's
why I love it so much because they're
just so it's so associated with Boston
sports I'm really shouldn't be talking
about this because it's a pointless but
Duncan so then we were we were like do
we wear the ugly sweaters we'd be
matching do we go that lame are we gonna
be that stupid and we're like yeah let's
do that stupid yeah who are you guys
excited to see tonight I feel like Liz o
for this one
no except for I cannot say Minnesota
Vikings anymore without saying Minnesota
Vikings I'm saying that oh you did no
it's not because I only know that one
song I would say Katy Perry but she's on
stage right now
missing
I'd like to see firework live I think
we're gonna miss it
she's gonna sing that right now I would
imagine no she's not gonna that's oh
that's a almost a deep cut at this point
that's like nine years ago whatever but
it's a kind of Christmas eh I guess Oh
et that's an old song that song how's
the great one PT but oh yeah ET full
circle moment right there I have to ask
you Chris soules came back here earlier
and he talked and he was very open about
sort of what he's learned over the past
couple of years and he said that you
guys were very supportive of him how is
it to have him here tonight and to be
sort of opening up back his life to the
world in a way yeah I think it's great I
mean Chris has been a friend and it was
just a horrible situation that happened
a couple of years ago and I remember
first hearing about it and it's that
moment where you're just your heart
sinks and you have no idea what's gonna
happen because Chris is such a good
friend and it was tragic what happened
and you know you go through so many
emotions as a friend because you just
don't know the situation and you're
hearing rumors about what exactly
happened what didn't happen and I'm just
really happy for him right now that he's
hopefully being able to get back to his
life because I don't think that he was
able to for the past few years and so
we'll still be there to support him we
watched football together a couple
Sundays ago yeah yeah we watched the
Bears for him he's is such a kind guy so
good hearted and
I'm just happy to see him out here
living no he said you learn a lot about
the people who stick by you through hard
times and I think it says a lot about
you guys that you were willing to sort
of do that I think there was a lot more
people out there that you know were I
don't want to give us credit because
there were more there were people in his
life that were way more involved than us
it was you know that did a lot more and
so we're here for him if he needs
anything and I think you know that's all
I can really say about it
big holiday season for you guys your
first one is a married couple how does
that yeah you would start it off with
matching sweaters first married first
time we're men were married first that
were married
yeah well Thanksgiving was fun his
parents came down and we had a joint
family Thanksgiving and it's really just
funny to be like at dinner tables and be
like you weren't married and you're
married we're married it's just a whole
different feel it feels nice secure
feels old you know you're like oh my
parents are married your parents are
married yeah I'm married you at the same
time I go mom I put a load of laundry in
the laundry room so you can get today
it's like your parents are forward right
yeah kid an adult the same time so yeah
that very much are you guys starting any
new traditions well now it's a tradition
to wear ugly sweaters to Jingle Ball
yeah we started that last year new
traditions huh that's a great question I
mean we've talked about a lot we don't
foresee ourselves I mean we both want
kids but we're I think we're gonna wait
until next year so the question out of
my mouth let's say I so I feel ready
you're going to witness so there'll be
no new tradition maybe this year but you
know next Christmas
knock on wood hopefully there will be a
new tradition in sight
yeah you're saying next with the
tradition of hat of being pregnant it's
just like a new thing Christmas she will
maybe possibly be with child I remember
one time I shouldn't even say this
friend of mine who may or may not be in
the bachelor family I remember we were
talking about plans right and like kids
and family and blah blah blah and she
was she she or he they may have kids and
they were like yeah it's nice to have
plans okay and then planes planes change
okay it was really it was just like the
perfect wine thank you guys so much have
fun tonight you guys are always the best
and congrats on yeah I appreciate it
though
I appreciate it you guys are always fun
to talk to yeah
[Music]